[Music]
computer-generated imagery or cgi has
allowed for a massive range of new
stories to be told through movies and tv
black holes dragons superheroes oh my
i used to think cgi was some sort of
mysterious nerd magic that could only be
made by a powerful super computer at a
hollywood studio however i began my own
visual effects career when i realized
this wasn't the case
i realized that this was an actual
career path for thousands of artists
across the world i now work for a small
production studio called corridor
digital and we're known for using visual
effects to make fun short films on
youtube
you have to go faster
i love bringing things to life that
didn't previously exist and at the heart
of that for me are visual effects i am a
big fan however not everyone shares my
excitement about that and i get it it's
fine sometimes the effects just suck
sometimes you can just tell that is fake
and that's a bit of a bummer you watch
movies to enjoy stories but when the cgi
is bad it can take you out of it last
year for instance i walked out of the
theater having just seen black panther
now i really enjoyed this movie however
i was disappointed by the quality of cgi
particularly in the final fight scene
and it turned out i wasn't alone either
i asked twitter what movies they thought
had bad effects and they overwhelmingly
responded with black panther i am
hesitant to just openly criticize the
effects of the movie because a lot of
overworked artists helped create them
and i think about those artists a lot
but you know who doesn't think about
them basically everyone else you see
there's a common misconception regarding
how cgi is created people tend to think
effects are just made by computers
rather than actual people like an
instagram filter they think we just
press a button and poof movie magic
hollywood vfx pipeline however is really
complicated first you need proper onset
data acquisition to feed to the camera
tracking department where a bunch of
sculptors will then build detailed 3d
models to send off to texture artists to
make them look real and once lighting is
set render farms are managed 24 hours a
day to spit out clean looking cgi only
to land on a compositor's desk who
performs video photoshop to blend
everything into a final image
and if you didn't get all that it's all
right just know that every one of these
steps can only begin once the previous
step has been completed but if any of
those steps break down those next in
line are stuck polishing a turd as we
say in the industry you'd be surprised
how often that happens and yet visual
effects are so ubiquitous now that they
just don't wow us anymore we've become
desensitized and while not everyone is
an artist everyone is a critic if
anything is slightly off audiences can
tell it looks fake even if they don't
know how so what tips us off
well the first sign is that it simply
isn't photo real the lighting or
materials don't represent reality well
enough to look like a real photograph
it's a simple idea but a pretty tall
order and it's a little unfair even
because we all have a lot of experience
with reality we see it every waking
moment everything that you can see has a
material property that defines how it
reacts to light and therefore how you
observe it things like color
reflectivity physical texture
transparency skin for example is
slightly transparent and absorbs the
light that hits it you don't realize it
but you know exactly what all these
visible properties are without even
having to think about it so when they're
off you can tell and it's not just about
how cgi looks but how it moves too bad
cgi can oftentimes look photoreal when
paused but emotion looks wrong
there are three main ways we replicate
motion in the digital world and one is
animation where the motion is designed
from scratch
another is through simulation which is
putting some rules into a program and
then letting it decide where things
should fall and finally there is motion
capture which records the movements of
an actor in order to most accurately
replicate the subtle ways in which they
move depending on the film usually a
combination of these three techniques
are used and the recent planet of the
apes movies are actually great examples
of this motion capture provides the core
movement of the skeleton and face
something that's super challenging to
create without reference those gray skin
suits aren't just fashion statements
after all but added on top of that are
simulations of muscle and hair that
actually react to the motion of the
performer when added together this looks
more natural but that's not to say that
there isn't any human intervention
animators usually have to step in to
make alterations so that not only
everything works together but that it
fits the vision of the director and the
results are exciting because through
this we can create digital characters
that perform like real people now these
days cgi is usually pretty solid we've
gotten good enough at rendering and
moving things to pass initial inspection
but there is one area of scrutiny where
only absolute perfection is acceptable
realistic human faces
people can scrutinize faces to an
incredible degree i mean they are the
defining feature in how we tell each
other apart so when we try to create
human faces we can experience what is
called the uncanny valley
this graph plots our emotional response
against the realism of a fake person the
far left signifies characters that are
super obviously not real people so
there's an emotional disconnect but as
they get more realistic we begin to
connect more gollum from lord of the
rings for instance is very lifelike and
we can even connect with him as a person
but his proportions are all wrong so
you're never fooled into thinking he's
actually human the familiarity just
isn't fully there it's the same reason
why we enjoy animated movies like the
incredibles but feel disturbed when
watching the polar express
you see something weird happens when
characters begin to get this realistic
they fall into the uncanny valley and we
can have an adverse reaction i'm willing
to bet you won't describe this as cute
meow and there have been many examples
of human cgi characters that fall into
this valley in fact it's something that
artists are still struggling with today
even star wars rogue one which had some
of the most realistic digital humans
ever created failed to be absolutely
perfect we may not be disturbed anymore
but we can still instinctually identify
something is off i mean maybe it's the
lighting or the eyes or the motion of
the lips honestly
i don't know
currently i can only think of two
examples that truly succeeded in
climbing out of the uncanny valley take
a look at this shot from the movie logan
[Music]
you may have figured this younger
wolverine was the result of some you
know simple digital makeup but nope hugh
jackman's face was 100 recreated and
rendered and this just blows my mind
because there are dozens more examples
like this in the movie but no one could
tell the other example is rachel from
blade runner 2049 and this is a
character from the original movie but is
cgi in the sequel do you like our owl
the quest to make her unquestionably
real took the effects team over a year
and the results were so convincing i had
no idea she wasn't real
bladerunner 2049 ended up winning the
academy award for best visual effects in
2018 and at first i was honestly a
little disappointed you see i felt war
for the planet of the apes deserved the
oscar because creating a cast of
lifelike characters is an incredible
technical achievement but here's the
thing great visual effects are about
more than just technical achievement it
has to be about artistic expression as
well and that is something 2049 had in
spades i mean that movie oh that movie
had an aesthetic
and academy voters were swayed by the
visual artistry that and some voters
apparently really thought that the
planet of the apes crew were just really
good at getting the apes to behave so
well on camera
remember
we just press buttons
but for real though movies like these
push the bounds of technology and manage
to do one very important thing create
the ability to tell better stories at
the end of the day that is the most
important role of great visual effects
they need to serve the story when the
effects of a movie are flashy just for
the sake of being flashy it doesn't
serve any purpose other than to create a
spectacle event you know what i'm
talking about the disaster movies the
monster flicks the transformers films
the justice league
more and more movies are relying on cgi
to hide a weak plot and that's causing
audiences to turn their noses up at it
they desire movies with real practical
effects
and i understand knowing that what
you're seeing is real and tangible can
be exciting but i think what people are
really craving is merely suspension of
disbelief when they notice cgi the
illusion is shattered so they naturally
just want less of that director
christopher nolan agrees with the
sentiment and strives to capture as much
as possible in camera he claims he only
uses visual effects as a last resort but
i believe that's not really the case oh
i have no doubt that if he could have
dropped anne hathaway into a wormhole or
burned aaron eckhart's face off he would
have
no no he just simply knows that cgi is a
tool and knows exactly how to use that
tool to make you forget that you're
watching a movie that was the magic of
jurassic park this movie came out 26
years ago and the effects are so good
they hold them to date but do they
though do they really
[Applause]
notice anything weird about this shot
[Music]
all right yes the raptor disappears for
one frame and yes that's actually in the
movie the effects were groundbreaking at
the time but if you really go back and
look at only the cgi i think you'll find
that they really don't hold up it just
doesn't matter because they were used in
such creative ways that for the first
time in history a movie made you believe
that dinosaurs were real
and i think that that's something that
the recent sequels failed to do because
on a technical level jurassic world has
far superior cgi but it's never really
grounded in reality it just feels like
it was too preoccupied with whether it
could use cgi it didn't stop to think of
it should normally though you only ever
notice cgi when it is bad in fact the
best visual effects are never noticed to
begin with they're invisible
david fincher is such a perfectionist
when it comes to creative control that
he would rather create digital blood
than to leave it up to chance by
splashing it around in real life this
team is just so good at it you never
notice
did you know that his movie the social
network has a thousand vfx shots in it
yeah the facebook movie has more vfx
than the 2014 godzilla movie like what
turning one person into twins who
interact with each other is pretty
technical stuff that hundreds of artists
worked very hard to make sure you
wouldn't notice but there is one final
factor that can really dictate the
quality of cgi and that is time
the biggest issue with effects today
isn't the talent of the artists creating
them but the time needed to do so
however movie making is a business and
more time means more money and release
dates are incredibly important to the
bottom line of a blockbuster so films
trying to meet deadlines can become
rushed and this was ultimately the
problem with black panther
now it's important to note that most of
the effects in this movie are actually
great but there were 2500 of them and
even though the work was divided between
13 different vfx studios there simply
wasn't enough time to do everything
properly they were re-filming the final
fight scene in october but the movie
still had to come out in february which
left only a matter of weeks to do all of
the effects for that entire scene from
scratch
the company that took on this challenge
has even won the vfx oscars for all four
of these movies and yet the results
prove that great cgi cannot be rushed
like all forms of art quality comes down
to a function of skill and time the
greatest renaissance artist took years
to complete their paintings and if i
tried to paint something great it
wouldn't matter how much time i spent
because i lack the skill and i think
you'll find that even great artists
would deliver shoddy work when rushed to
complete it
so in the movie industry where time is
finite artists have to strike a balance
no movie is ever finished it just gets
released
so the next time you're watching a
summer blockbuster even if the visuals
fall flat take a moment to appreciate
all the hard work that went unnoticed
visual effects artists are artists after
all they pour their blood sweat and
tears into these stories that capture
our imaginations and sometimes even
their best work may have been invisible
all along
[Music]
what you just saw was actually a tedx
talk that i performed at the university
of pennsylvania in march of 2019 and it
was an awesome experience but it was
also one of the most challenging things
i had ever done turns out making a ted
talk is pretty hard but we decided to
film the entire process so that we can
show you a behind-the-scenes look on
what it's like to give a ted talk so be
sure to subscribe to the channel so you
can actually see that video when it
drops in a couple days and now for
something that i've always wanted to say
thank you for coming to my ted talk i
really enjoyed doing it i hope you
enjoyed it as well but now for a word
from our sponsor audible because i'm
going to talk about an audiobook called
skyward by brandon sanderson one of my
favorite authors it's a story that
basically combines top gun with how to
train your dragon but like with
spaceships it's pretty great i'm
actually listening to this for a second
time because he's got a sequel coming
out in a month and it's all on audible
and speaking of audible you can get this
for free plus two audible originals when
you go to audible.com corridor crew or
by texting corridor crew to 500 500. now
if you're a freak of nature and
sanderson isn't for you that's okay
because there are audible originals
which are exclusive audio titles from
worlds as diverse as theater journalism
and literature and you can check all of
this out by going to audible.com
corridor crew or by texting corridor
crew to 500 500 to get your first free
audiobook today along with two audible
originals is great do it right now do it
do it turns out writing a ted talk is a
lot harder than i originally thought it
would be i just did all this stuff last
night i've written 5 000 words i think
i'm gonna pretty much throw all of it
away
i think i'm ready i'm not ready oh god
i'm not ready
[Music]